so it's 20 minutes
pretty fast yeah we're gonna
yeah 24 minutes is the usual time oh
there's a counter in there
yeah sorry but yeah
um
mean
[Music]
[Music]
i'm going to start off with a story now
this is not a bedtime story to tell your
kids
how many of you understand english
so you got less work to do
so i'm going to start off with the story
because it gives hope and inspiration
and this is one of the haters from the
past
and then we'll connect it with the
haters of today
how's that how many how many of you need
some translation right now
[Music]
the mama was a hater who actually
killed many of the was a participant who
helped kill many of the sahaba
he also tried to assassinate the last
and final messenger sent to mankind the
prophet muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam now can you imagine that he was
an enemy of islam
now what happens is he gets caught the
muslims are out on an expedition they
catch him bring him to the messenger of
allah
and now he's detained where in the
masjid
so the prophet saws comes to him and
says to mama
what do you have to say he says
he said look if you kill me you know
you've killed a great leader if you
want to ransom me name your price
if you let me go i'll be thankful
first aid second day same thing third
day
in the process of the days that he's
there is he tortured
is he tortured no is he treated
respectfully
yes i can't hear you guys fat is he fed
or deprived of food
he's fed and even from the food
from the prophet household so the man is
treated with dignity and honor
at the end same thing on the third day
he's asked
and the same thing is repeated from
there
the unimaginable happens he's let go
this is because
this is that expression manifested of
mercy so what happens from there go
ahead
we're doing a condensed version today he
comes back
shortly sometime later and he's wet i
can imagine he's dripping he's wet he's
coming back they just
now the sahabah probably build
wilderness also
they're like mama what are you doing
you're coming back and as he comes back
he says oh messenger he came to testify
that there's nothing worthy of worship
except the creator of the heavens and
the earth
and you o muhammad are the messenger of
allah
and then he said the famous words he
said oh
rasulullah there was no man that i hated
how do you try to say hey hater
there was no one
let me practice my father
now this is an example of a man who was
a hater
and beyond and then he became a lover
so you can imagine now now we can deduce
what was going on in the masjid
what kind of things was he exposed to
when he exposed because look
the evidence in islam is overwhelming
the purpose of life
people are in universities they know
their purpose they're at the bus stop
they know their purpose
but they're in life and they don't know
their purpose in life
and islam lays out everything crystal
clear
while the philosophers to this day are
debating
islam comes and explains things
not just on blind faith but look with
rational logical evidences go ahead
now let's bring it back to a times
magazine
article in the late 70s
in april they published a
report talking about exposing
the amount of books over span from 1800
to 1950 now can you imagine
over a span of 150 years over 60
thousand 60 000 books
written against islam haters of today
so that's over one book a day
al jazeera just recently did a report
just in australia
in 2017 they caught about
3 000 articles that had mentioned
islamic or muslim and write in the same
articles
associated with violence terrorism
radical extremism
so this is the hate machine that's being
funded
you have a business that's being
perpetuated
of hate over a quarter of a million
dollars is spent annually creating fear
and having
spreading misinformation and lies and
distortion
about islam now wrapping up because i
want to respect the time
is that we have been blessed with this
scene
as we're grounded with it it's our duty
to do our best
to not only live it with the best the
best manners and best etiquettes
but to go ahead and this story is
supposed to give us
hope to know that even the worst of the
worst of haters and i
interviewed people from the english
english defensely
uh individuals who are political parties
that were out there
propagating hate against islam but when
they got exposed
to islam they made the human connection
the tao hit them
and they were sincere hearts of change
people just like
who were haters at one time they became
lovers and are standing
in the sauce worshiping the one god and
coming
so i leave you guys with that we
established a program one of the first
and only islamic tv talk shows helping
to clear the many misconceptions and
there's a ton of them
highlighting people's stories and the
good news is that now we also have these
show
ball so we need your guys support anyone
that can help
we want to get all these programs
translated into the bosnian language
and it's another tool that you can use
really out there
to go ahead and help share this message
because as i often
say if you care you share so anybody
that would like to help and contribute
you can see
our brothers taught it and to go ahead
and see how you guys can
support and you can always find me at
the show.com thank you guys it was a
pleasure being with you
a lot of exciting topics you don't want
to miss out you want to be here every
friday
and then we'll try to give you some
short reminders in between but you can't
get that if you're not coming back to
the show
every week fridays we'll be releasing it
god willing inshaallah
subscribe right now and enjoy
all of the content that we're going to
be putting out for you
thank you peace be with you so i'll make